this video was made possible by better
help.com / Pakman where you can get
affordable online access to a licensed
therapist through text phone and video
chat
just click the link under this video ok
it keeps getting worse and worse and
worse for Donald Trump Supreme Court
pick Brett Kavanaugh first he was caught
lying multiple times in previous
confirmation hearings then a woman named
Christine Blasi Ford made allegations
that Kavanaugh attempted to rape her
during high school then a second woman
named Deborah Ramirez claims he forced
her to touch his penis while in college
at Yale and then attorney Michael
avenatti claimed generally that he has
witnesses who will say that Brett
Kavanaugh was involved in plying women
with alcohol in advance of gang rapes
during his time at Yale in college and
the latest it seems like every six hours
there's some massive new newsworthy
event in this case Michael avenatti is
now saying that in those that those in
charge of the hearings and potentially
in charge of saying we've got to stop
this and do an investigation are
ignoring him and that the next step will
be to bring forward the third accuser
who avenatti says will be going public
in the next 24 to 48 hours so last night
avenatti took to twitter he said he's
been sending letters and interactions
with the Senate Judiciary Committee that
he has had and regardless he has no
response saying quote we still have not
received any response to my detailed
email of this morning to mr. Davis and
the committee 10 hours ago this is
unacceptable
moments ago I once again asked for a
rose to for a response and answers C
email below what are they hiding other
than Mark judge of course Cavanaugh's
friend allegedly also involved in some
of these incidents so then cut to last
night on CNN michael avenatti now saying
that in the next 48 hours which I guess
means since this was last night we're
now down to only like a little over 24
hours to go that the woman he is
representing I guess we're assuming it's
a woman although it hasn't been made
explicit will be coming forward
in the next 48 hours here's avenatti
last night what do you believe that you
know from your latest client or is it
clients plural well at this point Chris
its clients we're gonna make a public
disclosure within the next 48 48 hours
of detailed allegations as well as the
identity of at least one of my clients
relating to what she witnessed and
experienced concerning Brett Kavanaugh
and Mark judge and ultimately we're
gonna let the American public decide
who's telling the truth I will explain
to you in very simple terms what's going
on here okay it's it's extraordinarily
simple Republicans don't want to deal
with this that's it when it was one
accuser Republicans figured let's have a
hearing let's play Kate them let
Christine Blasi Ford tell her side of
the story let Brett Cavanaugh show up
deny everything say I've never the same
stuff he said in that Fox News interview
he gave yesterday I've never assaulted
anyone and it's just all crazy and then
Republicans can say we did it let's vote
now they already are planning to have a
vote on Friday potentially the day after
these hearings would take place but now
as the number of accusers continues to
grow a second woman Debra Ramirez has
come forward a third woman that avenatti
is representing is planning to come
forward the ex-girlfriend of a
Cavanaugh's friend mark judge says judge
described to me a very similar incident
of alcohol riddled gang rape of the
style alleged by avenatti they are
realizing they being Republicans that if
they let everybody speak and investigate
every claim they're gonna have to slow
this thing down and they've never
actually cared about the content of the
allegations they just wanted to get Ford
on record and say listen she came
forward
we gave her a chance not convincing
we're ready to vote now it's getting way
more complicated to do that and they're
starting to have to ignore allegations
and they might actually succeed that's
the worst part of this they may actually
get Kavanaugh confirmed before all of
these accusers are hurt because they are
so many of them coming out of the
woodwork now yeah and I think it's fair
to say too that Democrats are doing some
political posturing right because the
allegations and the women are
coming forward now as opposed to a
couple months ago when Brett Kavanaugh
is nominated and now of course he it's a
good question you have Michael avenatti
getting involved and he's a character
but yeah it has no bearing on whether or
not the accusations are true and exactly
a key point I agree with you that
avenatti still continues to strike me as
not exactly the greatest character in
this entire sort of Greek tragedy that
has become the American politics under
the trump administration I'm completely
on board I think we got to be careful
about where were they a couple of months
ago because we know why people don't
come forward and at this point I just
don't think it's it's a fair criticism
that bears on the truth of it which you
said you said it regardless we've got to
adjudicate these to the extent that we
can big picture what's going to happen
here I don't know I think that the
accusers all need to come forward ASAP
and it needs to be so much pressure put
on the committee and put on Republicans
that they can't just ignore these and
say we heard from Ford and we're gonna
vote on Friday that is the scenario that
needs to be prevented at this point